uh so you got him and they hand them
over to me and i haven't seen them
before so some numbers i might have to
you know pull out of the ether but we'll
check them over the breaks okay and
if i don't know an answer i'll just say
you know chuck i don't have a clue go to
the next one we know that's not going to
happen but that's cool and i must say i
am impressed with the fact that you sit
there
you have a computer in front of you but
i noticed that you always make sure that
you close it before we start this and i
think that's your way of saying that's
right
that's right
that's right the computer up here is
where this is coming from bring it on
yeah okay all right here we go
all right so let's uh let's go to
facebook first i mean we got some google
plus we got some twitter here but let's
go to facebook first i'm going to start
off with a fun on a fun note this is
from matthew vixel okay
what could the future of sports look
like in space
well harry potter fans get a chance to
see a version of quidditch implemented
in microgravity what if that's what
increased or decreased gravity have on
water sports so two three real questions
there i'm more i'm more concerned about
the quidditch but
wait wait last i checked
in quidditch
they fly right that's right
so
one of the advantages of flying is that
you're not so much thinking about
gravity because you can go anywhere in
the three dimensions that space gives
it's we people who can't fly who are
limited to the two dimensions of earth's
surface
so the broom
which they steer by leaning
left or right and has natural lift to it
if you were in the
vacuum of space
or free-falling anywhere then there is
no sort of net gravity force on you the
buoyant source of the broom would be
unnecessary
in fact if it still had a buoyant force
it wouldn't know
where to buoyance you towards
right right if if you're
if it wants to lift you up
and in space there is no up right you
have brooms going every which direction
so basically quidditch would look like a
chinese fire drill yeah it would be a
quite a random looking so you'd have you
need surely they're wizards so they
would specially design a broom for the
specifics purposes of space quidditch
that first of all
now if now there are two kinds of space
quidditch you might imagine one that's
in the vacuum of space in the rearing
space helmets
or one that's on a planet that has an
atmosphere and it just has a slightly
different gravity
right so if it's a slightly different
gravity it's the same it's the same same
game so that's not even interesting but
if you're in the vacuum of space uh then
let me see so so there'd be no
atmospheric drag
on uh
on anything you throw
and the what do you call the little
birdie thingy with the flappy wings um
um
oh god
oh now it's killing me oh you know we
know how about we know what a zillion
harry potter fans said oh my gosh how
could you not know that it's the snitch
it is the snitch yes nice job
that was impressive i got they're all
from my kids
so the snitch of course we presume is uh
it doesn't have broom powers but is
actually aerodynamically supporting
itself with flapping wings yes like like
like a hummingbird like a hummingbird
style yeah so
wings are useless in zero g
that was the odd thing about naming the
lunar module the eagle
that kind of
worried me a bit in 1969 apollo 11 the
lunar module
what does neil armstrong say when he
lands houston tranquility base here
the eagle has landed
and their patch was an eagle extending
out its wings this because every mission
has a
uniquely designed mission patch this one
had wings extended outward and it was
hovering over the lunar surface
no
it doesn't work
okay a bird on an airless planet is a
brick
so yeah the snitch they have to redesign
the snitch for that one so it could be
fun but yeah yeah okay okay